in this capsule we will see reminder of
derivatives of function imagine that we have
a f function that take as argument
a variable that is a scalar
summoned x and imagine that we want
have information about our
function f specifically of
information on how this function
love varies if I vary on the x argument
ore to get that kind of information
when we can use it's the calculation
of the derivative of the function of which
community drifting and a function f
2 x compared to his x argument of two
ways either f bonuses of x or sometimes one
see there a hood is rather dve 2 x /
dx is by definition what that is
matches
that's the limit when you take a gap
deltort and that we tend towards zero of f2 ex
plus the deviation deltort - f2 x / the value
of school and so that's their ratio here
change of fgx when added
delta to the value of x / the value of
the gap but when taking the quarters
in question and that time to this
which is interesting with the steal
it is firstly the sign of drift
and will actually give me the direction
of increasing the function so between
others if we have a positive sign for the
drift and without meaning that f 2 x is going
increase so exactly to the inverted if
the negative sign and the xv has rather
decreases
when we will increase x also the
absolute value of the drift actually
give us the rate of increase where the
rate of change finally from our
function if we change the value of x
so the absolute value that is high
it means that a tiny change
of x will involve big changes
in the value of fgx
then in absolute drift and who
small it means that very little
changes of direction barry x in
entry now for the rest the
notation rather than using so
the idea here i'm going to use rather
symbolic is the symbol of drift
and partial which is more general than the
derivative and we will see the drift and leave
later donate but all I'm going
do it in my notation changed
use of a six by the symbol of
partial debris that looks like this
so let's see some first drifts
and simple visual defects
so if we have a constant to whom
regards mankell and the drift and the
constant compared to xcm now
drift and 2x to hate or hate and
where is a constant of speak no x
it's going to be nxx to hate neighbors the
derby of the function the oc ii x dad and
that will match an on x plea
high of the potential ex of x will not do x
it's very simple it's just
the exponential of excellent enough of that
if you want to get derivatives for
function compositions one has by
example that the derivative of a constant
time a function is 6 compared to
x it's going to be the constant time drifting
and drifting tours and a
hate function versus x that
will have hate once f 2 x hate
monthins times the derivative of the function
then of his high debt of the ex
potential of a function of x will not do x
it's going to be the exponential of freaks
times drift and techs and so
similar the derivative of the loch of a
function of x with respect to x this
step 1 on f2 x times the drift and of
fgx relative to fixed so we notice
in fact we basically have the
first term which corresponds to the drifts
visual but with eve 2 x rather than x
that we multiply on the right by the drift
and mtx versus x making
some examples then imagine that we
be calculated the derivative of the function
with what is equal to 3 xx to the map
so drift and bishops this is the
der veer of three ex arast cap par
relation to x the der vis of a function of
x times a constant is the constancy
which is three times the function that was
the other part of three times and xanaka
so there are four and the drift and of
mixer to 4 versus x is too much
for four times exhales at 3 so we have
3 x 4 dosing times excellent to you
who are our tv of our public service
then his wish the derby of the function
of fgx which is the exponential 2 xo because
is divided by 3 so we have the dvd rw
eaks he derived from the experience there
would have divided by three compared to x
that's going to be equal to using hervé's
the ex potential of our function the
beginning of the national exhibition is
simply the exponential of the
function times the derivatives of the function
inside that we have to do
so the der wiel excels at 2/3 by
compared to those of his hell this drift
is here here so we still
the exponentially these excerpts released
by three times the drift and 2x to the body
is divided by 3 so we have explored
a constant which is one in three so
that's equal to the constant one on
three times the drift and a mix at
square by appear
there is only this part of
the dlv has completed the square dereliction
compared to aix and 2 xx so having
two medupi left xx so the drift
of rtx and exponential equal of xo since
and divided by three his two-thirds for
exponential election because is
divided by 3 white
now for combinations of
function of the compositions functions a
little more complex we have that drift and
of two functions of xj dxy h2x by
ratio to an x6 simply the sum of
hervé so the sum of the hervé of
gdx in relation to aix plus the derbi of
gdx by paris now the derivative of the
product of two functions dxg of
the exploit h2x it's going to be drifting and of
league lodgings will be done by x times the
function h2x plus function gdx times
the drift and axes of the experts
devices and finally the drift and of
generix / hdx so the function ratio
it's going to be the derivatives of the numerator j2x
compared to xx 1 / hdx - j2x from
departure hdx squared times drift and
h2x compared to x for example so
imagine that we are the function xx
the exponential dx is our function
public then drift and f2 xperia
x1 but we'll pretend it was
our explicit gide was neutral h2x
in the formula we had previously
we will see the drift and 2x in relation to
xp the exponential x + x times the duration
from the nancy expo the bike experts the
derbi two experts in paris xi 1 so we
at the exponential 2x simply here
predicts reliving the experience and
to excel differential of xxx times
the elite experience then the drift and of
exponential xp of x this is
the experience of the ex more expo
the exponential dx were doing another
example
so let's not imagine the function f 2 x
which is exponential of x / x so in
this case we can use the formula
we saw where we had a gdx function
that experiential Israel 2 x / one
hdx function which in this case would be
simply
x in this case if the formula tells us that
the drift and 2f of the exp report x that's
the drift and gdx so the experience
yale 2 x by ben xx 1 on our
function h2x chi x - j2x that he is
possible to x / hdx squared which would
x squared times drift and h2x so
the video x versus x the derivative of
yen experience 2 x is the experience
of x the empty dice extra excess 1 so
we only have drift and fgx
report to x and the derby of the experts at
paris xe - experience her talking
the d926 pro bike is the feat
that of an expert / x - the experience and
the x / x in case we could have drifted
this result in another way that
will actually give the same result
so it's an alternative derivation
could have seen this here as being in
do j 2 xx 1 h2x where I have extracts
the exponential 2x as before but h2x
it would rather be an x ​​and as we go
to see that gives exactly the same
result
that is to say that we have evoked the rule
for the function product whose
lifetime ex compared to x it's going
to be the derivative of the ldx experiment by
report to xxx
my function h2x qe1 on x plus the
jdx function which is exponential of x
times the der wiel and hdx which in this case
here and one on x that we will end here
that it appears to live the experience
of an exponential exponential explorer
of xx 1 on x so / x the drift is
of 1 on x so one on aix actually
can advance as the ex partial exploit
during x at the - la dvi two excellent
- hours would be less x at least in
less so minus two which is equal to
damask - hours on x squared
then we would have that here we do not rattle
exponential of x times the hervé of a
on exqi and - hours on aix because and so
we will divide by mitsou square
we would have before 1 - which appears
ok so that's another way of arriving
to the same result
so to make the relations of a
data function it's normal to have
different animations but they
should arrive at the same result